i find out what tristan is doing with
the rest of the world a courtesy would
be not doing it
but fine if you do it you're not even
going to give me a heads up for the rest
of the world
it's just an additional slap in my face
it's humiliating i'm embarrassed khloe
kardashian giving her honest reaction to
tristan thompson's paternity scandal
during the kardashians finale khloe
faces the harsh truth after her sister
kim tells her about the court docs that
revealed tristan fathered a child with
someone else did you see what i sent you
no hang on
what
what
is this so he's been lying to you what
did you know about this no
oh my god this cannot be happening
everything's gonna be okay
no matter what everything's gonna be
okay and for chloe all she can think
about is the last few months with
tristan at the time the pair had
reconciled after his prior cheating
scandals i'm replaying
every event every
grand gesture every
trip is the finest man
you are
every day
where's tutu
there she is
[Music]
every whatever i see you good job
did you make a wish
all of that was a lie
coco also shares what hurts the most
about the entire thing everything is an
act of betrayal everything is a lie
everything is
manipulation it's deceit to tristan have
every opportunity to tell me yes was
tristan going to tell me if there wasn't
a baby involved absolutely not and that
shows a lot about his character the
entire thing is despicable and during
times like this the kardashians lean on
each other for support which is exactly
what chloe did when kim came over for a
late night pj chat and got real about
the issues in her past with kanye west
if people knew what what my relationship
really was like i think they would be
like how did this last this long yeah
but i can live with myself knowing that
i tried everything humanly possible
to make a situation work and so i could
walk away being like absolutely
guilt-free and i feel like you could at
least say you had a family you tried
everything in your might and you can
look your daughter in the face and say
that and chloe feels just that when it
comes to her and tristan's four-year-old
daughter true i gave it my all i've
never felt guilty we got to give it to
ourselves
we are some strong
[ __ ] oh we are
and despite going through heartbreak
multiple times chloe still believes in
love isn't that crazy and get this she
says that she wants what kim's found
with boyfriend p davidson pete is so
sweet i don't know him really really
well but from what i do know i think
it's
really drama free it's really easy
and i think that's something that's the
end goal everyone wants that fairy tale
everyone wants the happily ever after i
think that's the hope
love shouldn't be this hard ahead of the
show's premiere chloe echoed a similar
sentiment to e.t the family really
adores the snl funnyman
now the goal is finding someone to do
nothing with it's the best because you
don't do everything with totally but
it's crazy to be distracted with people
you can be with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing cheers to coco finding
someone to do nothing with who also is
her perfect match
[Music]